eu
[Aplausos]
gostaria de convidá-los a conhecer um
pouquinho do meu mundo eu sou um dos
milhares e milhares de jovens desse país
que teve a sua vida impactaria
diretamente pela educação a educação me
levou a lugares que nunca pensei está
mas na minha formação o tanto
Educacional e profissional eu tive uma
aliada a tecnologia a tecnologia
caminham lado a lado com a educação
durante toda a minha vida mas a
tecnologia ela não foi apresentada mim
com um laboratório de última geração
leve escola ou muito menos um computador
na minha casa até porque da minha fazer
o tive acesso aos a tecnologia foi
apresentada pelo meu pai Luiz Cláudio
que é técnico em telecomunicações o meu
pai me deu Meu primeiro videogame ele
falou é a partir daqui é com você
realmente foi porque quando o controle
de videogame tia brava ou eu tive que
juntar dinheiro para comprar outro eu
tinha que aprender a consertar e foi
assim que eu aprendi eletrônica Mas eu
não parei só o controle eu ia para rua e
vê no lixo é televisão rádios ponto de
videogames pegava levava para casa para
saber como por que e para que funcionava
Oi Renata Então eu fui apertando nesse
mundo da tecnologia através da
curiosidade o que eu sinto queria saber
porque isso rodava porque estás em dia
porque esse aqui está quebrado
e a tecnologia nos traz isso no história
curiosos e no todo decorrer da minha
vida tanta tecnologia quanto à educação
e à uma presente aos meus 16 anos
eu fui apresentado um novo mundo ONU o
mundo da física e o mundo da química
e nesse mundo nessa aula na escola a
gente tava tendo bater no seu do clima
sobre hidrogênio
E eu achava outro incrível porque
segundo a professora o hidrogênio era um
combustível de foguete
Oi e não fala de um sub tópico falando
sobre um processo chamado eletrônico
eletrólise nada mais é do que um
processo físico-químico em que a gente
passa uma corrente elétrica por uma
solução Salina já de sol e a gente
consegue fazer divisão de moléculas de
hidrogênio e oxigênio da água e assim a
gente consegue gerar o gás hidrogênio a
primeira coisa que passou na minha
cabeça é Cara isso é muito maneiro
preciso fazer em casa então com um bom
cientista maluco eu cheguei em casa
escondido da minha avó Com certeza e eu
peguei o pote de palmito dois parafusos
um cano de ar condicionado
uma fonte de computador água e sal e eu
fiz o meu primeiro reator de hidrogênio
em casa e aquilo era algo lindo para mim
eu liguei funcionou gerou hidrogênio mas
eu vou te guardar esse gás Foi aí que eu
vi cara dá para guardar em bolhas de
sabão e o guardando esse já desenrolei
sabão só que eu queria saber a melhor
parte disso durante a aula é que quando
você queima hidrogênio o resultado não é
CO2 era dois A então voltava fogo nessas
bolhas EA explosão de hidrogênio é algo
lindo primeiramente crianças não faça
isso em casa e depois pai por favor não
me odeiem por ensinar
o juiz por uma duas na terceira vez o
reator explodiu
explodiu dentro do meu quarto foi a
tampa por dentro do vidro para todo lado
água para todo lado e a minha vó que é
uma senhora de idade a cor todo sujo e
perguntou o que que é isso que tá
acontecendo aqui primeiramente eu falei
vou Relaxa é só um filme só que coisa
ela abriu a porta do quarto filme de
terror era dentro da casa dela porque o
quarto estava todo explodido minha avó
virou para mim falou filho a partir de
hoje todo o país mais veio uma
experiência nessa casa
o e aquilo me doeu como com cientista
maluco me deu bastante só com as carinha
a viajar e fiz a mesma grande área de
novo explodiu de novo
e nessa questão de explodir eu carrego
uma frase comigo que é se explodir eu
estou no caminho certo
eu estava no caminho certo compra de um
processo é feito em laboratório
utilizando o que eu tinha de acesso na
minha casa utilizando gambiarra com
aprender química e física eu aprendi
isso na prática
o decorrer da minha vida novamente é só
apresentado uma nova tecnologia dentro
da faculdade na Faculdade eu fui
fundador de um laboratório média sem
saber viu fazer a mínima ideia do que é
cultura Americana
e ainda só agora agora eu fui
apresentado a uma impressora 3D que hoje
é algo que me motiva hoje algo que eu
faço é algo que me faz fazer tudo o que
eu sou hoje essa impressora 3D era uma
impressora gringa de uma marca chamada
Maker bota a minha primeira reação foi
eu preciso ter uma dessa
realmente ela era linda para você tão
perfeita só faltava fazer café entrei no
site da de que bote em 2018 e ela
gostava de 15 a 17 mil reais é a
primeira coisa que passar na minha
cabeça dá para comprar um Fiat Uno
usados
para capotar o Corsa com os amigos
e eu vi cara não tem como eu tenho
acesso a tecnologia compram
e eu pensei de novo novamente comigo
mente quando eu sempre faz-se um gringo
pode fazer isso porque Pelos poderes e
vestidos a mim pela gambiarra eu não
posso então estudei por seis meses em pó
dos nacionais e internacionais videos do
YouTube e aprende toda a teoria de como
construir essas máquinas de impressão 3D
é legal boa trás dos sons ele foi atrás
destes tubos nos ferros-velhos da minha
comunidade do Complexo do Alemão
é mas eu fui encontrada havia deles
dentro de uma cooperativa de catadores
numa comunidade próxima chamada jacaré
quem vai chegar do Rio Jacarezinho eu
encontrei a culpa uma lá eu encontrei o
meu Nirvana da gambiarra onde eu tinha
acesso a todos os somos que eu queria
praticamente de graça
a e depois de um cartão de crédito rádio
680 reais 10 centavo eu gostei a
primeira impressora 3D e foi algo um
amor à primeira vista porque a partir
das impressora eu fiquei tão motivado
nesse mundo de tecnologia
nesse mundo de gambiarra nesse mundo de
sucata de impressora 3D para o meu TCC
bom e como todos jogos universitários
não poder do ódio eu escrevi um livro de
90 páginas ensinando como construir
impressoras 3D ainda esse livro eu
dedico as minhas impressoras a minha mãe
dona Maria Simone todas as impressoras
que o recebe o nome de Maria
hoje eu vejo que às vezes impressoras
são mais do que uma ferramenta de
tecnologia hoje eu tenho quatro Marias
em 41 desiste instituições no Rio de
Janeiro sendo utilizadas como ferramenta
de mudança levando para favela a
tecnologia e levanta também Um novo
aprendizado por jovens atendidos por
essas instituições
O mãe o time tocou é o seguinte a
impressora 3D ele é possibilitou a
entrada no novo mercado aprender coisas
novas que eu não aprendi dentro da
faculdade eu aprendi arriscando com
gambiarra e curiosidade EA partir da
impressão 3D o fogão mas tratado querem
fio aí que eu criei com o único objetivo
de vida a democratização da tecnologia
dentro de parcelas
o objetivo desse Startup era nada mais
do que criar uma escola de tecnologia na
minha comunidade do Complexo do Alemão e
a partir daí gerar uma mão de obra
qualificada eu queria ver jovem preta e
favelado desenvolvedor de tecnologias em
por cento ao mês de favela transformando
todas as favelas do Brasil e não só a
mim verdadeira sua cantas a partir desse
projeto com as impressoras com aprendi
praticamente construído com gambiarra e
muita sucata eletrônica eu tive acesso a
lugares que eu nunca pensei a ir tem
mais tempo aprendi que eu nunca pensei
ganhar tive acesso aí o Valdo o ar alho
mas nada disso para mim importa mais do
que a minha primeira palestra de sobre
impressão 3D no colégio público
foi quando eu achei minha motivação de
vida que a democratização eu parei de
três 20 minutos para uma turma de 100
alunos do Colégio Padre Manoel da
Nóbrega e São Gonçalo no Rio de Janeiro
troquei 2:30 respondendo perguntas e a
maioria dessas perguntas era eu consigo
fazer eu tenho capacidade de aprender eu
tenho que capacidade de fazer algo igual
você fez
E aí comigo ok cara homem negócios e não
venha fazer impressora 3D barata a minha
vida é compartilhamento de conhecimento
in Rio 2020 eu vi o poder transformador
da tecnologia ao vivo
e em 2018 eu tinha uma impressora e
deixei 2019 e três horas dentro do meu
quarto todas elas feitas com muito
carinho grande ahi sucata eletrônica
essas impressoras trabalhavam 20 horas
por dia algo voluntário de um projeto
chamado sos3 de corrigir 19 onde a gente
conseguiu proteger em favelas mais de
mil pessoas com faces filmes e impressas
em impressoras feitas com sucata
eletrônica
e foi nesse momento que eu vi o poder
transformador e social da tecnologia
é legal eu vou ter um pouco para vocês
da minha jornada até chegar aqui mas a
vida é e sempre foi democratizar e vá
desenvolvimento tecnológico adiante uma
vela eu queria se vai expor jovem da
favela
é a parte disso eu realizei uma pesquisa
de campo hoje eu entrevistei 30 jovens
aleatórios do Complexo do Alemão
E eu perguntei para esses 30 jogos Você
sabe o que é cultura Negra
resposta foi não sem por cento de jovens
mas é uma resposta que eu já esperava
Olá eu sou preto favelado e morador do
Rio de Janeiro e conhece todos os
estereótipos do estado na pele o Rio de
Janeiro para quem não conhece ele é
dividido entre o antes e o depois do
túnel antes do Duro é minha vivência é
onde eu moro depois do é aonde eu
trabalhava sendo professor numa escola
onde os alunos a partir dos 6 anos de
idade tinha acesso a computadores sala
de informática
aulas de programação aulas de robótica e
um laboratório do meio que completo e na
minha quebrada os adolescentes mal
tinham com uma sala de informática com
todos os computadores funcionando ou na
internet banda larga de qualidade de
suas casas então era uma resposta que eu
já esperava por causa da desigualdade
social que tem no meu estado
Tu vais como a noite de educação eu
lembrei de um ensinamento dos maiores
educadores que esse país já teve Paulo
Freire Paulo Freire nos ensina que
ensinar é entender a realidade
conhecê-la para depois transformá-lo a
partir desse pensamento
eu pensei comigo mesmo que eu tava
querendo levar uma cultura nova da
maneira errada eu queria jogar água ela
abaixo de jovens ou uma cultura
americanizada
eletrizada informatizada dentro daqui do
nosso país
eu ir para aí que eu pensei e repita a
pergunta meu jovem você sabe que é
gambiarra a resposta foi automática
todos os jovens me responderam o meu pai
espera o meu avô e mestre a minha casa
praticamente foi feita com gambiarra
gente gambiarra nada mais é do que uma
tecnologia brasileira um design sem por
cento do Penguin uma cultura Maker Uma
Brasileira antes de Maker existir
gambiarra já tava na terra o que eu
entendi nessa pesquisa é que
eu quero levar uma cultura tecnológica
totalmente nova a minha comunidade eu
tenho que falar a mesma linguagem do
colo foi criado a linguagem favelado e
periférica eu comecei a entender e
pesquisar sobre gambiarra e ver como a
grande ar é uma tecnologia que nos faz
avançar tanto quando ligamos os nossos
smartphones é trampo de nossas redes
sociais
e aqueles vídeos de gambiarra que às
vezes parece totalmente assustador e
incríveis ao mesmo tempo a gente ele
comentários Cara isso é muito louco e a
gente vê comentários também de gringos
elogiando essa criatividade nós o que eu
quero passar para vocês é que
e devemos valorizar mais a nossa
tecnologia brasileira EA partir dela ver
que a grande a ratinha seu poder
transformador tecnológico quatro social
a primeira minha fala mas eu não convite
Nasa eu sei que você faz pesquisa
história do nosso país sei que ela vai
ficar colonizar mar mas convidar vocês a
pesquisar o nosso povo o Brasil um dos
países mais inventivos e criativos de
desse mundo e Nasa Vem estudar gente que
a gente não tem
obrigado pela oportunidade pelos bancos
emprestem
E aí